in a grim fortress on the coast of
europe an anonymous prisoner sits in a
cell his thoughts consumed with
vengeance
a one-time no woman who commanded armies
he's now been forgotten by the world
his name scratched from history betrayed
by those closest to him
the man's only hope is to somehow escape
and visit retribution on his enemies
sound familiar well if you're a fan of
literature you're probably now thinking
of edmund dante the wrongly imprisoned
hero of 19th century french adventure
masterpiece to counter monte cristo but
while everything in that opening
paragraph could apply to alexander dumas
famous character
we weren't talking about anyone
fictional no everything in that
swashbuckling opening
really happened to a real man his name
was thomas alexander dumas and his
adventures would inspire
his son's greatest novel a former count
who served in france's revolutionary
wars
thomas alexander dumas was a one-man
army he fought alongside napoleon
single-handedly defeating
scores of enemies and he was worshipped
as a hero and
he did all of this while being proudly
defiantly black
betrayed in his lifetime ignored by
history this
is the epic tale of general dumar the
real count of monte cristo
when he came to write his swashbuckling
epics like the three musketeers the
great french
author alexander dumas wouldn't have to
look very far for inspiration
as a boy had spent hours on his mother's
lap transfixed by her tales of a daring
soldier
a romantic hero as brave and chivalrous
as he was strong
but these hadn't been regular bedtime
stories the sorts of tales we might read
our own children
it's all been true the stories dumar
heard had been about his father who died
when the boy was only three
those tales were far stranger and far
more exciting than
anything dumar would ever write the
story of thomas alexander dumar or
alex as he preferred to be known began
not in france but thousands of
kilometers away
is santa ming which we today call haiti
and it begins not with his birth but
with the meeting of two very unlikely
people
alexandra antoine david de la peletiere
was an immoral aristocrat looking to
make a quick buck in the colonies while
waiting to inherit his family's title
since santa mar in the 18th century was
the richest colony in the richest empire
he'd come to the right place his brother
was already a successful plantation
owner but antoine himself would prove
way too lazy and way too much of an
to get into the sugar game
stealing a bunch of his brother's slaves
he instead vanished off into the
mountains to live a life of leisure
since this was a time and place where a
white guy's leisure usually meant
exploiting black people
it wasn't long before antoine decided to
buy himself a lover
today there's very little we know about
marie cesar de mar
even her name is uncertain some sources
give louise instead of marie while the
meaning of her surname dumas has been
a source of constant speculation
something it means of the farm implying
she was a free woman managing a sugar
plantation
on the other hand the name may have
indicated she was owned by an estate and
that antoine bought her when she was
still enslaved
it was from this union between a loose
white aristocrat and an exploited black
woman
that thomas alexander dumas was born
from the moment he first opened his eyes
the boy was plunged into a legal gray
area
mar in 1762 was a place obsessed with
racial hierarchies with
whites firmly at the top and black folk
firmly at the bottom
unlike america's slave system though
sandomar's pyramid of exploitation
had a whole middle category those of
mixed race
it was in this category that young alex
dumas found himself
although dark-skinned alex was nearly as
free as any white in the colony the
local coloreds as they were called were
seen as completely distinct from the
enslaved blacks and
frequently held positions of power this
meant that alex spent his first 12 years
with the freedom his mother could only
dream of
able to wander the back roads near his
father's estate treated
almost like any white man but almost
isn't the same as exactly and alex was
about to find out in the worst way
possible
how santa mar exploited people like him
in 1775 antoine got the news that his
relatives back in france had died and
the title of marquis was now his for the
taking the only trouble was
he couldn't afford the boat fare and his
brother was still too pissed at him to
lend him the money
so antoine did something utterly
unthinkable something so
immoral we can't believe we're actually
saying it
he sold his own son to slavery
[Music]
it is impossible today to know how
thomas alexander felt as his father
handed him over
took the money and then vanished off to
france aged only 12 this strapping young
boy was now somebody else's property
in sandomal this could only be a death
sentence the violence meted out to
slaves in the colony was
sadistic even by the standards at the
time while france's black
code was meant to protect the enslaved
the reality was one of whippings
beatings mutilation and an extremely
early death
thankfully it's a system alex would only
exist in for a short period of time
in late 1776 with his title and
inheritance secured antoine suddenly
sent
for his enslaved son age 14 alex was put
on board a ship to france
the moment he left san demar he also
left behind his life as a slave
metropolitan or mainland france had
never allowed slavery and
by simply traveling there alex
automatically became free but it wasn't
life as a freeman that was awaiting him
in europe
it was the life of a gentleman so here's
the weird thing about antoine despite
being content to literally sell his own
son
he was also determined to make sure that
the same son grew up to be
everything he wanted in an heir antoine
showered the boy with expensive clothing
gave him lessons in everything from
philosophy to dueling and horse riding
it must have been head spinning for a
teenage boy used to life on a small
estate in the caribbean
especially when he moved with antoine to
paris then the greatest city on earth it
was in the french capital that alex grew
to a six foot two muscular hunks a
sort of guy society girls formed over
and
thorn they did at this time having dark
skin in paris wasn't always a
disadvantage
well seen mixed race jean de la couleur
lib from the colonies made up a small
but
vital part of the social scene alex
dimar slipped into this world like
a hand into a perfumed glove he was
visible at the theater at fancy salons
and ballroom dancers living a
life of glorious success this was the
era of marie antoinette remember france
for the aristocracy was a whirlwind of
glittering parties the
starving masses in the street could only
dream of yet while antoine's world
allowed alex to live like any other
society aristocrat
society also never let him forget that
he was different in september of 1784
for example alex was at a play when a
young white man began
hurling racial abuse when alex tried to
fight back the young man's cronies beat
him
and forced him to kneel before their
leader although the police intervened
the young white man got off scot-free
it must have been infuriating for thomas
alexander as if he was living in a
twilight world half in a place of
privilege and power and
half in a place of racism and depression
perhaps this feeling
of both belonging and not belonging
explains
what happened next in 1786 age 26
alex suddenly announced that he was done
with his life of leisure and wanted to
enroll in the army
at first antoine refused then he agreed
but only if alex never used the family
name again
so alex enlisted in the queen's dragoons
and when it came time to give his second
name he didn't use his father's
but his mother's he would now be thomas
alexander dumas
until the day he died
[Music]
despite his noble background alex didn't
join the dragoons as an officer
he started at the bottom assigned to
some backward ass town the lowest rank
where he divided his time between
getting into fights and chasing local
girls
there he had a reputation as a loudmouth
with a volatile temper but
also a gifted fighter who was harder
than anyone in a single day
he once fought three duels talented and
tough as he was though
it would be events that made alex dimar
famous specifically
one of the biggest events in western
history on july the 14th 1789 an angry
mob stormed the bastille paris in prison
turning
all that free-floating rage at france's
unequal society
into social upheaval it was the kickoff
of the french revolution a time of
dizzying violence and world-changing
ideas
the biggest of which would land just one
month later
on august 26 1789 the revolution's new
national assembly issued its first great
document
the declaration of the rights of man and
of the citizen
article 1 men are born and remain free
and equal in rights
no matter what the color of their skin
just like that a shining new era
of racial equality was born well that
was the idea at least we'll get to why
things didn't quite work out a little
bit later
for now just know this document struck a
chord
deep within alex dumas despite his
father's aristocratic background from
that moment on
alex was a die-hard supporter of the
revolution he would
fight for its ideals no matter what yet
while metropolitan france really did
seem committed to this whole liberty
egalite fraternity thing
the same couldn't be said of the
colonies back in san diman the right
resistance to the declaration
would snowball into a slave uprising
that sparked a hideous war
for alex though his heart was no longer
in the caribbean but it was
here in europe when the national
assembly under the swear of the radical
derandists declared war on france's
neighbors in april 1792
dimar was only too willing to fight for
them it was the opening of the french
revolutionary war as a near decade of
upheaval that would bring europe to its
knees
it'd also be the making of tomas
alexander dumas
remember how alex loved fighting duels
well for him the war became a chance to
do something he loved
all day every day the same spring war
broke out he made a name for himself by
capturing a group of 12 austrian
soldiers without firing a single shot
barely had his officers had time to
finish saying dan that was good
then alex had burnished his credentials
further by leading a mere four horsemen
to attack an austrian garrison
there were 50 austrian soldiers against
them but dumas horsemen of the
apocalypse they won
easily from that moment on it seemed
like nothing could stop the young man's
rise
along with his fighting skills and
strength alex had the good fortune to be
a committed revolutionary at a time when
non-radical officers
were fleeing the army or getting purged
in this new equal era what was to stop
him from
reaching the very top
it was during those first years of the
war that legends began to collect around
thomas alexander dumas
on the absurd end there was the rumor
that he was so strong he could get on
his horse reach up and grab a beam of
wood and start doing pull-ups that
lifted the horse off the ground that's
right alex zuma was basically a chuck
norris meme before
chuck norris was even a thing on the
still absurd but also true ends there
was the tale of how he met his wife
in the first months of the war as chaos
was gripping rural france abandoned
brigands attacked vilier cottere
they were threatening a bourgeois local
girl marie louis laboratory when the
dashingly handsome dumar came charging
into town like a one-man through
musketeers and saved her life
after the two fell in love alex asked
lebo ray's father for permission to
marry her since he was still an early
pirate pop laboratory told him to come
back when he got his officer's
commission and became a sergeant
tomorrow rode away and he's come back
shortly after having been promoted four
ranks above sergeant
monsieur laboure wisely allowed the
marriage to proceed as the months passed
the revolution's promise of racial
equality
began to pick up steam as an officer
alex was second in command to the
chevalier de san jorge
then famous classical composer who
likewise had been born to a rich white
dad and enslaved mother
their li jean noire was the first all
black fighting unit in europe an elite
regiment of swordsmen prepared to die
for the revolution
mostly though it was their enemies who
did the dying in yet another
insane but true tale alex once tried to
lead his men up a sheer wall of ice in
the middle of the night
to surprise an austrian battery at the
top they turned the austrians own guns
on them
leading to around 1 700 men immediately
surrendering
with badassery like that it's perhaps no
surprise the national assembly
approached alex about
going to san demon to end the slave
rebellion but alex seemingly had no
interest in his old home or maybe he
just didn't want to join that inferno on
what could clearly be the wrong side
instead he stayed in france in august
they made him general aged 31 dumar was
now the highest-ranking black european
soldier
this side of the roman empire and still
his star kept rising late 1793 was spent
leading 53 thousand men in the alps
terrifying the austrian so badly that he
earned himself the nickname
the black devil but this was just
propaganda with some
good old-fashioned racism thrown in
while he was a powerful fighter
especially in close quarters
general dumar was no devil whereas
plenty of other revolutionary era
generals rolled out the guillotine
whenever they entered a new village
alex had his guillotine burned for
firewood whereas other generals ordered
summary executions for anyone slightly
to the right of robespierre
alex issued pardons to civilians for
political crimes it was an attitude that
earned him the mocking nickname
mr humanity it also nearly earned him an
early grave
in 1794 dumar was sent to fight in the
von d a heavily catholic region of
france that
gone into rebellion against secular
paris the revolution had now gone
fully off the rails louis xvi marie
antoinette had been guillotined
robers pierre and the committee of
public safety were in charge and
the reign of terror was in absolute full
swing
in the varsity something called the
infernal columns were marching across
the landscape
slaughtering anyone who stood in their
way as a general in the region alex was
supposed to follow suit
instead he forbid his men from
plundering and refused to slaughter
civilians
in the reign of terror such leniency was
enough to get you killed
denounced dumar was stripped of his
command and sent to paris to face
justice
from being the poster boy of the
revolution it's suddenly fallen to one
of its bitterest enemies
in 1794 this could only mean one thing
thomas alexander dumas was
certain for a date with the guillotine
in the end it was sheer dumb luck that
saved general dumar while he was
languishing in jail awaiting execution
the national convention finally turned
on robert pierre on july the 27th 1794
or nine thermador year two in the
revolutionary calendar
the tyrant was denounced and overthrown
rather than dumar it was robbers pierre
who went to the guillotine
as his severed head dropped into basket
the era of jacob and terror reached its
bloody end
in the wake of the thermadorian reaction
political prisoners like dimar were
released by now slavery had been banned
across the entire empire
black foe could full citizenship the
right to vote the right to study
alongside their white peers
over in santa monica the french were
even reluctantly recognizing the former
slave tusala of ature as their
official representative in the colony
but even with these great strides dumar
seems to have had enough in 1795 he
declared that he wanted out that he
wanted to quit the army and go back to
normal life by now france was under the
rule of the corrupt
reactionary directory while less into
removing heads than robespierre had been
they still weren't the kind of guys you
said no to so when they told alex his
resignation was unacceptable
that was that the only change they'd
allow was to transfer duma
away from the alps where he kept
quarreling with his superiors
to the italian front they had fight
under a promising young general from
corsica
a young man extremely into bicorn hats
and conquest
on paper alexander dumar and napoleon
bonaparte they should have been bffs
they were both talented in the field
both ambitious both part of a new
generation brought to prominence by the
revolution
heck bonnie's wife josephine even hailed
from martinique a colony
into marshall's backyard in real life
though sings would quickly sour
although napoleon initially hailed dumas
bravery for doing bonkers things like
single-handedly securing a bridge in the
face of an entire cavalry squadron the
two men quickly began to show
signs of rivalry that might have been
fine if they'd gone their separate ways
when the war ended in october 1797 but
the directory had other plans
rather than leave two popular generals
standing bored until they decided to
remove them from power
the directory encouraged them both to go
on an expedition to egypt
today napoleon's 1798 egypt expedition
is famous
for its scientific and archaeological
advances it should also be famous
for being an utter disaster at first
general dumar was able to pull off some
astounding cavalry victories but it
pretty soon became clear that the french
were in an untenable position soon after
landing the british under nelson had
destroyed all their ships and blockaded
the port
now they were stuck in egypt as enemy
armies marched over land towards them
unable to get reinforcements or
do anything but watch as the expedition
spiraled out of control
under this insane pressure the
relationship between demar and napoleon
completely broke down
dumar publicly accused napoleon of
wasting resources and portraying the
revolution's goals and
strongly hinted that he should be one
leading the army napoleon for his part
was outraged when he discovered the
locals thought the tall powerful dumar
was the expedition's leader while
he was merely his servant but the real
blowout came
after an informant told napoleon that
dumar and other generals might be
plotting mutiny in the tense meeting
that followed it was decided that
general dumar should return to france
right away on march 7 1799 alex boarded
a boat fully intending to return to the
republic to return to his wife to return
to his glittering military career
sadly he'd never make it as the ship
cast off that fateful day thomas
alexander dimar and napoleon bonaparte
were still nearly equals two powerful
rivals who were popular heroes
before the year it ended that would have
all changed one of them would have
seized power and become
the first consul of france while the
other would be betrayed
forgotten and left to rot in a dungeon
far from home
[Music]
so here we are at last the moment when
alex dimar will be betrayed and locked
away like the counter monte cristo
unlike his fictional counterpart though
alex would never get to take his revenge
the problems began on the voyage home
the boat soon turned out to be
unseaworthy and was forced to pull into
port for repairs
unfortunately that port was in an
italian kingdom that was very much
against the whole
chopping off the heads of kings thing
that france was currently into
as soon as the ship docked alex and the
other frenchmen on board were taken as
prisoners of war
locked up in a naples dungeon dumar
waited for the directory to bargain for
his release to pay whatever it took to
secure the release of one of their best
generals but the days of the directory
were already over
on november the 9th 1799 also known as
18 premier
year 8 napoleon bonaparte returned to
paris overthrew the government and made
himself ruler of france
and well you could probably guess how
eager the new first consul was to secure
his old rival's release
in the end thomas alexander dumar
languished in prison for 20 months
during that time the conditions of his
squalid cell physically broke him his
jailers slipped him poison not enough to
kill him but enough to leave him
partially paralyzed and blind in one eye
when he was finally released in late
1801 it was only due to a sustained
campaign by his wife
at that time the damage had already been
done not just to general dumar but also
to the revolution
despite coming up in the same era of
equality as alex napoleon had no need
for
racial justice not long after dumar's
release the first consul issued a law
reinstating slavery in france's colonies
he sent an expedition to attack santa
mon and restore
white rule while it would ultimately
fail it would destroy one of the other
great black generals of the revolution
tusola overture who would die in a
french prison
in france itself interracial marriages
were banned equality was binned and the
clock turned back to a grim
era the revolutionaries assumed that
they're left behind it was in this
miserable new system that alex would
spend
the last years of his life although the
ex-general was entitled to it napoleon
refused to pay his pension and forbid
anyone from mentioning his old rival's
name
broken beaten down and penniless alex
and marie louise moved back to villier
cottere
there on february 26 1806 aged only 43
thomas alexander dumas died of stomach
cancer at the moment of his death
general dumar was leaving behind a world
in which he no longer had any part
in 1804 napoleon had been coronated
emperor crushing the last of the
revolution's ideals under the jackboot
of tyranny a few months before that
dumas old home of zandamore had ceased
to exist declaring independence as the
country of haiti
the first free black republic in history
the declaration had been accompanied by
all french citizens being killed or
expelled a famous french general like
dumar could have never gone back
perhaps the saddest thing though was the
birth of his son alexander dumas
when the boy was born in july of 1802
his mother had been overcome with relief
to
see that he looked white after all she
only had to glance at her broke and
rejected husband to see how france
treated its black men
in the wake of his death thomas
alexander demar would be written out of
history despite being one of the iconic
generals of his era only a single statue
was ever made of him no one would write
books about his exploits
until the modern age well almost no one
when general damar's son finally grew up
and became a novelist it would be to the
memory
of his long dead father that he turned
for inspiration
in tales like the three musketeers and
especially the count of monte cristo the
spirit of alex would be channeled into
tough romantic heroes brave men who
fought honorably
even when their enemies didn't brave men
whose lives had far happier endings
than their real-life counterpart it may
not have been how we wish to be
remembered but in a sense
these stories would give general dumar a
sort of immortality
a way for the world to always remember
this brave
remarkable man so i really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below don't forget to subscribe and as
always
thank you for watching